8 news now continuing to celebrate
hispanic heritage month and tonight we
are shining the light on one local
mexican neighbor he is not making waves
not just because of his culture but
because of his talent he is the only
latino with a solo performance in the
newest show on the strip and he is
living out his dream every night
i feel so proud of my
my cultures jose ponce says he is living
his dream on this las vegas stage is
this your ultimate dream yeah
performing ten shows each week and
hypnotizing the crowds with his skills
behind all the clapping and cheering he
says is a special appreciation that
comes from the latino community people
that came from mexico and salvador costa
rica central america when they
hear that they've been like wow
he's from there he's working here he's
part of us so
i feel very proud of it ponce comes from
a long line of mexican circus performers
where he says exposed him to the stage
life his true passion was the wheel of
death a 300 pound piece of equipment
that moves to his beat i think it's one
of the most dangerous acts
in
zurich and the world circus you control
the wheel it doesn't have an engine
inside that can control or stop it if
you fail they will keep going over time
his skills grew as well as his exposure
catching the attention of cirque du
soleil and catapulting him to las vegas
and into the company's newest show mad
apple inside the new york new york hotel
and casino my mind just flowed
i just went like wow
then i was the first one to
to be on the stage on the road that
with audience and i was like wow this is
amazing christian casadas 8 news now he
went on to say he's hoping to inspire
other latinos to take the stage and
share their culture with the world next
goal is to keep his family tradition and
teach his newborn the skills and perform
on stage together you can check out mad
apple by visiting our website eight
newsnow dot com